اعمده دخان اشتباكات مسلحه رصاص ودماء
انها سله العرب الغذائيه التي ملئت قنابل
ومتفجرات بدل الطعام والشراب
نحو سته عشر انقلابا عسكريا ومحاوله
انقلاب منذ استقلاله بعثرت خيراته واهدرت
مقدراته انه السودان
نحو 46 مليون مواطن نصفهم فقراء في بلد
فيه اكثر من عشره انهار طبيعيه ومائه
وخمسه وسبعين مليون فدان من الاراضي
الصالحه للزراعه في السودان ما يزيد عن
100 مليون راس من الماشيه اي اضعف ما
تملكه هولندا هنا تاسع بلد منتج للذهب على
مستوى العالم وثالث بلد منتج للنفط على
مستوى افريقيا
وفيما تتواصل الاشتباكات بين الجيش والدعم
السريع تعالت الاصوات شعبيا مطالبه بوقفها
على الفور والوصول الى حلول تلبي طموح
المدنيين بسودان مختلف
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات